tá igual a faca do sexo
será que essa faca corta mesmo em 3 2 1
11 o pessoal aqui quem fala ao dar que
sejam muito bem vindos à jogo ele é um
só que eu comprei isso que vocês
acabaram ver é uma impressora 3d e 3d
ou seja é uma pessoa que em vez de
imprimir em papel também ela consegue
imprimir objeto objetos tridimensionais
muito louco então pessoal os nós vamos
dar início a uma série é algo que
engrene qualquer coisa na impressora 3d
e sensual como vocês leram pelo título
hoje nós vamos tentar imprimir uma faca
eu acho que ela vai ser perfeita mas eu
não sei se ela vai cortar e eu não sei
se ela vai seguir afiada condição as
facas né mas é coisa boa deste vídeo é
porque nós vamos saber se eu falar que
realmente vai cortar e esta postura aqui
e não em prêmios o fax né é esta postura
imprimir tudo possa se quiserem tudo é
só muscular entre willian baixaram site
alguns mudam que é um trabalho um pouco
complexo mas ao mesmo tempo fácil nas
quais tem postura podemos imprimir
esculturas personagem uma mão robótica
tipo da primeira mão robótica mesmo
tempo funcional e até mesmo coisas
maiores têm uma bicicleta como tem muito
em baixo o que é que vocês querem que o
imprima pode ser tudo uma pistola e uma
faca uma faca não porque eu vou imprimir
agora as culturas personagem de
brinquedos barcos carros nem tem tudo
que vocês acharem interessante imprimir
e eu trago aqui o canal já sabem só
deixei muito lhe que neste vídeo porque
isso ajuda muito é que o canal e se eu
vou saber se vocês querem ver mais
vídeos deste tipo e por sorensen e se
vocês forem novos aqui no canal
inscrevam santo na força só que não
contam com muita força para se
inscreverem no poder em nenhum vídeo
aqui mas como é que sabe que ela
funciona como é que só quer um brinquedo
é que o contágio dizer eu sempre me umas
quantas coisas aí primeiro fuso lei é
tarefa já só com vocês podem perguntar
por feito está muito bem impresso ou
passar um vídeo de pinner que funciona
mesmo foi só colocar os regulamentos e
está a funcionar mas é isso como podem
ver o pessoal não imprime que duas
coisas que estão completamente
funcionais e por isso estou com muita
esperança que a nossa faca imprima com
sucesso tempo sempre sendo uma faca
deste tamanho e não só e se passarmos a
impressão ea faca ou explicar um pouco
como funciona esta impressora 3d esta
mesa de apoio aqui um objeto vai ficar
enquanto eu passei e impresso
vocês conseguem ver mas tem uma coisinha
e um filamento site da equipe sim aqui e
sair uma temperatura de mais ou menos
200 3 graus ou seja é muito quem tudo
finalmente está aqui atrás nem isso rola
aqui ó
hoje eu só estou linda hall e inclusive
eu já comprei muito filamento e alguns
deles são urgentes portanto que ser em
alguma impressão flushing brilha no
escuro e tem oque eu vou imprimir uma
faca porque tu bem curioso ela corta ou
não mas qual é um deu o que falar que eu
vou escolher a muito fraco por então
pessoal eu escolhi é querer amb qualquer
ambição sair é faca mais famosa do cs
gol e é sobretudo muita gente veja só
que o projeto como podem ver eu já tenho
aqui no meu computador e com esse
programa consegui controlar tudo o que a
emissora vai imprimir ela assim é muito
bonita e não só pois este processo é só
mandar imprimir 321 se explicar ou
imprimir solitário da faca e porque por
enquanto mas e ela é completamente
simétrica um ato é igual então precisei
por feito mesmo como eu quero eu vou
imprimir metade da faca e depois vai
imprimir a outra metade pois é só colar
e tá pronto eu acho que sim vai
funcionar ok já tá ligada e para lá 321
vai agora vamos ver o começo dessa
impressão da faca caribe
espero que funcione cérebro muito
curioso pra ver como é que vai ficar é
para ficar muito louco eu espero que o
fato ocorre mesmo que o foco agora que
estou dando resposta e como eu posso ver
como vai estar uma camada tão lisa que
pode custar
é isso que está nos expor ou só eu acho
que ela está aquecendo fundamental e ter
um pouco de filamento da mesma que eu
vou tentar trocar o michel o bonito só
vocês vão ver e tenta sair louco como
podem ver que já têm tudo formato da
faca e ela vai começar agora imprimir
por camadas num estranho estranho mas
não é que o cheiro a queimado é que o
racha queimada né é muito leve só lá
fora já está em primeiro em parecer mais
160 ainda eu vou deixar a língua própria
filmado para lá 321 vai
[Música]
[Aplausos]
vocês viram o time lapse muito rápido
mas acabaram de passar duas horas
eu vou duas horas só imprimir multada
facto mas só como ficou está muito linda
ok vou tentar arrancar aqui com muito
cuidado para não partir nada ou se o seu
serviço ocupasse quando o pai dele ainda
está muito mal então tem que ter muito
cuidado ao manusear aqui faca
eu acho que está um pouco mais fria e
vejam só tá igual a faca do sexto gol
igual e esta parte que sobra é só
arrancar o sol fazendo assim olha aí
agora tem que extinguir eu vou ficar
mesmo escura
olha só eu sai perfeito só vejam só este
atentado do nosso faca a prefeita meu
olha isso aí jogos encerrou
vamos lá estar então se ela é contigo
dia 31 vai meu speedy mesmo pediu isso
vou tentar assistir um balão e um saco
com muito boa hoje 21 321 pai
o u1 funciona mesmo é o ópio - ela é
fiada estava enfiado agora vamos ver se
é uma corda 32 anos ele sim eu vou ficar
eu vou arriscar mas não é que eu tenha
está não cortar e não faz nada não corta
claramente que não corta de plástico mas
mas vejam só que comprar só vou comprar
e olha o que eu comprei só que eu
comprei lixa é coisinha aqui vai ajudar
a animar a nossa facas o jurista e assim
ela vai ficar muito afiada eu espero mas
primeiro de tudo eu ainda tem de
imprimir a segunda metade da faca óbvio
e não eu vou mostrar outro time o eps
nem eu simplesmente vou ficar mais duas
horas à espera e é quando eu tivesse
notado que o vôo o irmão falou depois de
quatro horas em primeira facada e que
está ela olha só o faqueiro bits e
segundo totalmente impressa hollie steel
está muito ruim do encaixa muito bem na
mão tá muito dura e inclusive já
há algum tempo a pular porque não ia
fazer isso em vídeo é um pouco chato
então eu já comprei faca aí eu usei essa
coisa pra cortar à faca
usei que esta copa super treinar e os
aecistas também para cortar à faca mil e
deu muito resultado é outra muito maciça
olha aí ea melhor coisa aqui pessoal é o
bico olha aí tá muito fiado para a
encosta nele mesmo né
foi bom o que eu vou fazer através do
teste do balão eu acho que essa placa
hta muito mais potente e parou a 31
bairro
olha aí nem fiz muita força mas muita
força o op e ela conta mais pesada
aprofundar muito melhor assim eu vou
tentar agora furar o balão correlacionar
3211 vai tá muito afiada eu acho que ela
corta acho que ela corta e como eu tinha
dito que só vamos lá então a nossa luta
para tornar esta faca muito mais afiada
eu não sei se isso vai resultar mesmo
estará operando e até que seu até que
seu plástico só tá cada vez mais lisa
vou continuar a tentar
[Música]
o pessoal eu acho que ela agora está
muito mais afiada então vamos tentar
cortar agora alguma coisa fruta comida
olha eu tenho esse papel que ela teve
enfim é bem frágil mas vamos tentar já
conheça ou corta corta se ela só cortar
aqui na ponta é uma [ __ ] costas só
estudou até mesmo porque só vou tentar
cortar alguns elementos mas para isso
temos que ir pra cozinha embora agora
clique em algumas frutas como laranja ou
limão e uma venenosa mas lá está e qual
é o fruto que ela corta melhor ou se ela
portanto facto algum fluxo será que essa
faca corta mesmo em 321 vai não está a
contar isso não está a contar
não é que isso não está a cortar 10
estão fiasco estão todas voltaram a cair
vou tentar exportar falei tá aí eo prato
da faca mas pelo menos elas peta 30 e 40
ou 50 anos em java assim vai eu acho que
fui muito bem a faca te olha só como ela
corta o trabalho é o bico e é
precisamente o que já está destruindo
agora mesmo olha para isso todo torto e
até abril os nomes e olha e e em lei
agora um limão eo ricoexport o veículo
ficou no meio fica no meio do ano e não
tem escritura só veio aqui algo estreito
e vamos sair e agora falta só uma fruta
que é nossa banana e aipim banana vai o
deu o ok do economês
vejam só como fica a nossa faca tá
completamente destruída uma das coisas
que vou tentar fazer é mandar facol aí
vamos ver se ela quando que ele desperta
na terra é porque já fiz com um machado
e resultou em 32 o vai
não faltou não escutou na lei subiu
muito ruim a qual ela solta temos que
continuar a tentar algumas vagas é
persistência o que faz o sucesso
eu vou tentar acertar com essa faca que
eu já lá no fundo eu você está ali
dentro com uma faca
como é que eu vim pra cá só isso
então é isso só vou ficar porque
conhecido espero que vocês tenham
gostado do traçado e comentei muito em
baixo coisas que eram que imprima na
impressora 3d e deixei muito laquê neste
vídeo estão foram inscritos e inscreva
se aqui no canal e atingiu se nem
perceber em todos os viris e já sabem
aqui por cima vão ser dois vídeos que eu
não sei se vocês viram mas eu tenho
certeza que vão debater muito assistido
e aqui mas vocês podem escrever aqui no
canal da frente e só fiquem bem até
aproximar